this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we help people
build wealth do work that they really
love and create amazing actual
relationships open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five joining me today my co-host
ken coleman of the ken coleman show
ramsay personality number one
best-selling author talks to folks about
their careers and their jobs every day
we'll be answering your questions as i
said about your job doing work you love
about building wealth and anything else
jump in and we'll talk so ken um
a lot of stuff moving around in the
economy
yes a lot of inflation and recession
worries gas prices are enough to give
you a freaking heart attack
god i filled up my raptor and i just
about just laid down in the middle of
the gas station parking lot and held my
heart for a minute
oh man i mean because you fill up a
prius it's one thing when you fill up a
raptor yeah it's another man
i can only imagine wow
i bought houses cheaper than that back
in the day but oh my gosh
it's it's a thing and you go to the
grocery store and you you know you put
your buggy's half full of what it was
and it's just as much money it's almost
like shopping at whole foods every day
that's you know i mean it's like really
it's crazy and i used to call it whole
paycheck right but the uh uh
you know it's it's wild out there the
interest rates have gone way up on
housing um house prices of course have
gone way up in 20 and in 21 they're up a
little this year
um
and everybody's you know worrying about
a real estate crash now
and and and labor cost
to hire someone to get a job
you know i'm seeing a lot of comments
and stuff flowing through in our place
right now it's like how do i how do i i
can't even make it i mean i can't
inflation has just destroyed what was
left of my little budget
um but in my mind when i hear that
there's always two sides to each
uh budgeting equation the in goes income
side and the outgo side
i also know that they're no longer
paying people ten dollars an hour to put
the bread on the shelves they're not
paying them 20 to 30 an hour
to put the bread on which is why the
cost of bread went up by the way
it wasn't wheat
and it wasn't a shortage it's the cost
of labor oh and the diesel fuel in the
truck to deliver the bread oh yeah
that's built into that so that's why
your loaf of bread went up that's why
sharon bought some bologna the other day
and man that was a lot of money what
that's just it's real food but sharon
bought bologna oh for me yes
homegrown tomato big red onion big old
piece of white bread and
that's better than filet mignon man
don't you know anything i i just i know
you have a very pride a little bit it's
a redneck it's a redneck that was the
same man frying the bolognese fried a
little bit you put it on there oh man
that's about it you could take the boy
out of the way any sidetracked here but
anyway the point being that if your
budget is stressed ken
and your salary is fixed
it might be time to look that's correct
because you might be able to make a
whole lot more money somewhere else but
be careful because you could jump over
into one of these companies that have
lost their minds and are doing all kinds
of crazy butt stuff and then you get
stuck in the middle of the crazy butt
stuff oh yeah we're seeing a lot of that
now the facts are just give you two
different stories
when you change jobs we've seen over the
last year and a half you're looking at
about a 14
on average pay bump well i would cover
your inflation that's pretty nice
especially if you adjust your budget you
know i also saw a story recently on the
news about this couple that's uh they're
extreme frugal savers and budgeters
probably our kind of people and they're
like we're not even feeling the
inflation i know that when we do these
debt-free screams over the last six
months
inflation doesn't come up at all
so there is a way to do it the way that
we teach it works but uh let's give you
some good news about the economy just
reported on my show today that uh olive
garden
they beat their projections
uh and what they've done they've kept
their prices low and turns out families
like a lot of free bread sticks and um
you know bottomless salad
but
the point is my weight in both of those
right but here's a story that you're not
hearing in the media
when a restaurant like that decides you
know what we're going to keep our costs
where they are it's costing us a little
bit more but they got more people coming
in because they're offering things so
you hear all this bad news about
inflation and the economy we also saw
today reported today that for the first
time in seven months home sales spiked
in may so
this doomsday stuff we need to get over
it
well it it's those are good
anxiety and the fear
around filling up your car and almost
passing out is real absolutely right the
anxiety and the fear over you know half
the stuff in the grocery basket and it's
just as expensive as real
however
what's just as real is there's almost an
across-the-board increase in wages and
if you haven't received that then you
should talk to your employer because
he's getting ready to have to replace
you
yeah that's right and there's
opportunity like we've never seen before
we still see a level what we are paying
for a position at ramsey has changed
dramatically in 12 months based on the
marketplace that's correct in order to
get someone to do x or y or z
it is different than it was 12 months
ago and that difference is at least 14
percent that's correct that's the
average yeah so folks that's the average
of people that change jobs so we'll take
those calls today because dave's right
we don't want to chase just a paycheck
because that'll wear off if you're in a
crappy culture with gossipy people you
leave a good company and you go into a
bunch of crap and they're doing the
the woke agenda and then and you hate
that stuff and you all of a sudden
you're going to be spending all your
money on your time on that instead of
actually helping people doing work
correct so um
we're quite the opposite around here at
ramsey we're kind of boring old
dinosaurs and um and kind of proud of
that by the way but the uh um
anyway the the uh yeah so i mean you you
make sure you're going to a company that
aligns with your values maybe you want
to do all the woke stuff then go you
need to make sure they're doing all that
stuff um a lot of them are doing you
know they're going overboard with it
because they're just virtue signaling
that's correct and so if you leave a
good company like i mean we had a young
man that left here a while back and he
texted this weekend and he's like oh god
this place is a disaster that i went to
and he got he got more money than we
were paying him so he got a raise but he
went into a mess you know and so be
careful that you're not doing that or be
careful you're not taking a job that you
hate or be careful that you're not
thinking something's you know what it
was i had a another guy a friend of mine
left his position because he was gonna
work 20 hours a week from home
for more money
yeah now he's working 80 hours a week
yeah from home well there's a lot more
money yeah it's a mirage a lot of people
well here's here's what's unique about
ramsey solutions and we're always hiring
so you know you need to be checking out
ramseysolutions.com but we know from
research i spoke about this at our
entree leadership summit here are three
human needs that we all want fulfilled
at work number one we want to see
meaning and purpose in our work we have
a crusade mentality because we're giving
people hope and real practical steps for
life transformation at this company
number two we want to be recognized for
our unique contribution i can't tell you
the stories of people that are
executives here in this company who
started out as administrative assistants
and because we recognize people's hard
work we recognize their talent we give
them an opportunity to get promoted they
do here
i'm sitting on my operating board two of
them and then the third thing that we
need is we want a relationship with our
leader i cannot tell you how much this
company cares for its people it's a real
relationship with the people that you
report to if you don't have that find it
somewhere yeah find it somewhere and
make sure if you're going for more money
that you get that too or else the money
will be you'll be hating your life all
for a few bucks that's right but you can
help with inflation by either an upward
a raise at your current place
or a uh a move to somewhere else well i
work for the state well maybe it's time
to move somewhere else they're probably
not going to give you a 12 inflationary
raise this year and you probably can get
it somewhere else this is the ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite
gives you the visibility and control of
the things you need to grow like your
financials inventory hr planning
budgeting and more all in one dashboard
go to netsuite.com ramsey right now to
get their free white paper jump start
your cfo career
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five jackson
kansas city hey jack how are you
i'm doing very well how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
uh i had a question about uh purchasing
a vehicle in today's climate for my life
uh
the it would amount to purchasing two
vehicles at the same time basically
okay so riddle me what are you talking
about
well i've been i've been driving a
vehicle for about 20 years as my
everyday vehicle
i inherited it from my father brand new
basically he
he bought it brand new and then got
diagnosed with a terminal illness and
ended up passing away soon after
and so that was about 19 and a half
years ago
i've been driving the car
it's a subaru race car
um
long story short i've been taking it
only to dealers and my local dealer kind
of wrecked the last time they serviced
it trying to install a clutch
and destroyed the transmission and
did a bunch of damage
and basically ruined the car for me
so they're going to pay you for the car
uh they we made a deal we came to a deal
oh that avoided anyone going to court
and so they're going to sell me a new
car
and give me a bunch of money off on it
basically
the equivalent of the value of the other
car
yeah plus a little bit over i think
because
well yeah i'm sure there's margin in
that thing so
there's margin in them that are there
so you're getting a brand new subaru
yes okay so that that deal is done oh
base model basically that deal is done
and what are you spending there
what are you spending on that car uh
it's gonna cost about 25 000. okay
what's your household
income our household income is about
200
okay and you're wanting to spend one on
your wife's 20 20.
so here's the thing the dealer felt bad
and he told me i told him my wife needed
some work on her vehicle as well then
and he said
he would give her the same deal he's
given me if i wanted to buy her one
so
i wasn't thinking about getting her one
before he said that
he's going to give you the price of your
old car off of your wife's and your car
or just a good price
going to give me all the money he's
given me off my deal and he said he'll
do the same thing for her he'll give her
the same money off as if he wrecked her
car and just because he feels bad he
says
how much
how much value how much did they give
you for your old car
for the old car
uh it's leaking out of the head how much
money did they give you for your old car
oh for my old car yeah uh they basically
gave me about
four or four thousand for my car okay
and and then they knocked off how much
more the car then they knocked off how
much more they knocked off another three
okay so they're gonna knock 7 000 off of
another subaru if you buy two in a row
basically yeah and and your wife is
driving what now
she's driving a subaru that's uh
what's it worth got 100
uh that would be worth about seven or
eight except that it's got to have the
leaky head gap because that's what's
gonna cost three four all right so it's
gonna it's gonna you're gonna be able to
sell it for five right
yeah if i fix it no if you don't fix it
if you fix it it'll sell for yourself
maybe or eight
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's just it's drivable it's just got a
leaky head gasket and it's an old
freaking subaru now
what is your network
what is your net worth
net worth i just did a calculation i
think our if i go by just net worth
we're at about
230ish thousand i guess
okay
between equity you have the cash to pay
for all these
cars no
well only if i take money out of a roth
account or something so no we're not
buying these cars we're not buying cars
without i only have the cash to pay for
one car okay
okay
um but my mother's been telling me
you know maybe i should be buying some
reliable cars for you yeah maybe you
should but maybe you shouldn't be going
and taking your retirement money out to
do that you probably i'm going to pass
on this i'm going to pass on the second
one because i don't recommend people buy
new cars they go down in value like a
rock
except for in the last 12 months
um
uh unless they have a net worth of in
excess of a million dollars because that
way you can accept the blow on that so i
would save up some money and i would buy
your wife a better car that is used and
i would forego this sweet dealer's offer
which is really not that great an offer
anyway it's an okay offer but it wasn't
like he gave you like half off the
stinking thing or something so yeah he
basically gave up his margins is what he
did and he's got you back on the hook
for more work in the
uh and everything else in the in the
shop but no i i'll pass on the second
one i would save up and buy her a better
car and cash for it and i would not cash
out my retirement but we don't borrow
money to buy cars we don't buy cars
where the total of all your vehicles is
more than half your annual income and i
don't buy brand new cars unless they're
a million dollars unless you have a
million dollar net worth or greater and
here's why because they go down in value
and you need to be concentrated on
things that go up in value yeah and and
in this situation i'd go and fix the
subaru for the wife
and then save up save up you're going to
get a decent amount i think dave you're
right going to get seven or eight for it
if it's fixed up and then you put that
into the savings and all of a sudden
we've upgraded pretty substantially
without any kind of debt it is doable
people get the itch and i don't i don't
fix six thousand dollar cars at the
dealership either no
i fixed six thousand dollar cars
independent mechanics where the cost is
about half of what it is to fix a car to
dealership
and so um if you have a brand new
vehicle and you know whatever and you
spend a ton of money on it you make a
lot of money and you want to take it in
for the dealer to service it that's one
thing but you don't take a six thousand
dollar car into a head gasket job into
the dealership you're gonna pay double
what you'd pay with an independent good
mechanic shopping around so do some
shopping around i i'm not doing it no no
so a subaru with a hundred thousand
miles is just getting warmed up
yeah well that's okay i mean i don't
mind him moving up and no but you can by
the way
i forgot to tell you the federal law too
wife gets the good car
that's the federal law so that means she
gets the new one you get the one with
the bust the head gasket y'all about to
trade cars out so this is how that works
that's a marriage thing they're just
helping you oh open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
dylan's with us in scranton pennsylvania
hi dylan how are you
hey good afternoon i'm doing very well
how are you today better than we deserve
sir how can we help
good uh so i have a
general question
i took a job with a church in
philadelphia last year in september
they offered me a 60 000
salary but it's basically a package deal
i'm currently
23 years old i'm married i do own a
house with my wife we purchased in
december of last year
and
basically
part of the deal is that right now i'm
on my parents insurance
but the church does offer full health
insurance full medical
but i'm gonna lose eighteen thousand
dollars of my
salary so
the church is paying me that eighteen
thousand dollars currently
so i'm bringing home like fifty eight
thousand dollars your insurance would be
fifteen hundred dollars a month
i have no clue and i i had worked for
uh walmart prior to this and i know the
family insurance was a lot cheaper
and i'm just trying to navigate how to
approach this because i don't want to
get two years so basically from from now
two years from now i'm going to lose 18
000 of my salary due to health insurance
small church
um not quite um it's a larger church
they employ 350 people they do have a
full school their health insurance plan
sucks yeah it's bad
but you got two years yes
i have two years to prepare for this so
the reason i wanted to get your
professional advice on this was that
i'm trying to navigate what to do so
currently
i am a property caretaker and i'm an
apprentice to literally every trade so
i'm learning
mechanics i'm learning plumbing
electrical everything
with this job do you want to be
full-time ministry or do you want to add
one of these trades as a part-time gig
to supplement
which one i think my desire is to be
full-time ministry
do the trades on the side to make up for
the increased cost of insurance you got
two years to figure this deal out
go shopping on the health insurance and
see if you can't buy in the independent
market cheaper too but i would stay in
the ministry seat that's the seat you
want to be in don't let health insurance
drive you out of your dream yep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the famous debt free stage anthony
and larisha are with us hey guys how are
you doing well great where do you all
live morristown new jersey all right and
that is near
right outside philadelphia oh 15 minutes
okay cool welcome to nashville looks
like you brought the teenagers with you
what are their names and ages
aisha and joshua mm-hmm
aisha's 20 joshua's 19. okay not quite
teenager sorry about that all right
very cool good to have you guys all
right how much debt did you pay off
well we paid off a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars in in 48 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time uh we started out at about
seventy thousand and this year we are
looking to make about two hundred
thousand whoa whoa nice jump what do
y'all do for a living i'm an executive
secretary
and i
lead a shared services team oh very good
okay cool so nice income jump the income
jump early in that 48 month track or
late in that track later on late in the
track and also i i've got a consulting
business that i had but i decided to
actually start working it got okay so is
that what that did you sell something
big too no okay you just cash flowed
your way through this so
maybe 45 000 uh did i do that right yeah
forty five thousand dollars a year
roughly fifty thousand dollars a year
average through there good what kind of
debt was the hundred and eighty thousand
we paid off our mortgage whoa
way to go weird people normal's broken
you guys are officially weird how old
are you two i'm 50. i'm 50. all right 50
years old with a paid for house what's
this house worth
it's worth about 500 000.
i love it and how much is in your
retirement accounts well we're not quite
there yet we're about a hundred thousand
shorts from being millionaires all right
this is a 900 000 net worth
and you're 50 years old yes and you're
making 200 a year right you rock we do i
love it way to go man
that is so stinking cool so you're gonna
be in there in 20 minutes stock market
goes back up you'll be millionaire right
then that one thing oh my gosh man way
to go guys so proud of you so what
starts this journey four years ago i
mean you're like 45 years old and you're
sitting around and go uh we gotta change
what happened we did um dave we were uh
davish for like ten years
and we had never heard of you and well
then you couldn't beat davis you were
just ish yeah we were ish
yeah we were following larry burkett and
never heard of you're larry is hilarious
okay and then we heard this guy than i
am
he is he is he was yeah yeah yeah yeah
we thought we were doing all right and
then uh we were living in michigan we
kept hearing people talk about this dave
ramsey like who's dave ramsey
and uh it pivoted something in our heads
and then we moved and
next door neighbors to our left
they
were always going away seemed like
like they had like a summer house and
just the peace about them
made us stop and think wow we we'd like
to do that and then we had some other
neighbors both of them all very nice but
uh
just working hard always seemed tired
working on the boat always problems with
the boat we said we have to make a
change we're looking at our kids
and we had another friend a little bit
older and
he was doing a lot of good stuff in his
life and we said all right
we're mentoring people we've got aisha
and joshua and we're seeing how
listening to you and the tools that you
give
what it's doing to their lives we said
we need to do something different and we
hit it hard
every little bit of money money from the
consulting work anthony was doing in our
job we put it towards the mortgage yeah
so you're making like 70 you sit down
you look you got 180 000
we crank the shovel up we can get out of
this whole quick that's right yeah yeah
it makes it believable makes you want to
go do it it really does gives you hope
based on our income i thought
i said well i can do a little bit more
consulting i think i could do it in
about seven years but then i said you
know what
something happens when we do the dave
ramsey plan when people do it i said i'm
going to do it i'm going to put four
years down as my marker and we hit it
exactly four years i said oh i probably
should have put three years down yes
interesting i want you to stay on that
thought i know where you were going
because we've been here we've watched a
lot of these stories so you put that out
you said something happens to dave
ramsey people right
uh i want you to unpack that a little
bit more what do you see because that's
coming from your view you saw okay i've
seen this so i i shortened my goal
what do you think happens when people
get focused well i think you just start
concentrating on what you want to do
right if if you need money to pay off a
mortgage then you're going to find money
that's right our income went up because
i was working in a non-profit job i've
heard dave say a lot of times you don't
have to only do good work in non-profits
so i got a for-profit i worked with a
for-profit company doing very similar
work but i did at the nonprofit yet my
salary
just went up quite a bit
and then when i started consulting more
something interesting happened too as i
started paying things off more i didn't
need the money consulting like i used to
so then people would people kept calling
me saying hey can you work i said no i'm
busy oh oh please come work with me i
give them some
number that i thought was appropriate
and they just pay it i said well isn't
that interesting what happens when you
when you when you change your
perspective when you're not desperate
anymore
people respond to that and the income
goes up there's something about boldness
right when you're bold and you put
yourself out there
then providence moves it's a wonderful
quote by a german philosopher gerda used
to say that when we step out we're bold
providence moves in ways that we never
could have seen possible and that's your
story it's really amazing wow that's fun
way to go you guys well we also wanted
to say that so aisha is she's going to
be a senior at in college and joshua is
a sophomore in college and both of them
are going through college debt-free wow
yeah they've got scholarships they're
working you know yes they're hitting it
hard
they're doing a fantastic job so we
wanted to be sure that we absolutely so
what are they studying and where are
they in school
well aisha is going to graduate from
rutgers she's going to be a speech
pathologist
way to go scarlet knight
all
right
and
josh was in uh
in community college he's a business
major great good great two good roles
good decisions yes well done good
careers oh man you guys are so smart
you have completely changed your family
tree you're amazing you're amazing
heroes look at you i love it way to go
you guys there that is amazing so well
done so very well done all right we got
a copy of uh the baby steps millionaires
book for you because that's the next
chapter in your story as we said you're
about 20 minutes away from that so maybe
by the time you get home it'll already
be across the line but right there and
also a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away and uh the financial
peace university uh membership for a
year the brand new videos in that that
just came out best financial peace
university we've ever had if you've
already been through it you want to give
that away give that away with that total
money makeover book you can it's all
yours just to say thank you for making
the trip to nashville and to say we're
proud of you we are very proud of you
thank you so much thank you incredible
people very very well done
anthony and larisha aisha and joshua
from uh the philly area making a hunt
are paid off 180 000 house and
everything they're weirdos they did it
in 48 months making 70-200 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
[Applause]
i love it
man so powerful
ken
the thing that i didn't understand when
i first started teaching this stuff the
borrower is slave to the lender when
you're out from under slavery
more things come loose than just the
math yes
yeah and that's what happened with this
consulting work
i generally find that people make
different
better
wiser
more lucrative career decisions
when they don't have a knife hanging
over the top of their head anymore yeah
it's true because they don't have this
sense of desperation they walk different
than a slave does you talk different
than a slave does it change me
i made different business decisions with
cash
than with debt oh yeah i make better
business decisions when i don't feel
threatened by the
marketplace i'm not threatened by
inflation i'm not threatened by
real estate prices i'm not threatened by
the cost to fill up my raptor even
though it does make me want to pass out
but i'm not threatened by it because i
don't have any debt yeah and it puts me
in a completely different position and
that's what happens your income
generally will go up
more rapidly
and more
and and both not only will it go up more
but it will go up more rapidly than if
you were not working a plan because
you're an independent thinker you walk
with a swagger it's a different world
yeah it's a big deal well done i'm so
proud of those guys what a great family
change their family tree debt-free
college and everything
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
well it's time for us to talk about the
real estate market everybody's asking a
million questions
should i wait to buy a house is it a
good time to sell
is the housing market going to crash
what's going to happen with interest
rates
on july 14th we're hosting a free
special live stream event called
real estate reality check george
campbell rachel cruz and i are going to
answer all your questions
unpack actual data
not your brother-in-law's emotions
not somebody that watches too much fox
news or cnn
where they're in freakout mode they're
at we're actually going to look at
actual data and history
and put this whole market in perspective
and uh we'll go ahead and spoil our
alert tell you the market's not going to
crash
and we're going to show you exactly why
and what you're facing
this organization at ramsey is always
about telling you the truth
as we can perceive it as we know from 30
years of experience in these markets and
the truth usually revolves around hope
we're not in the business of selling
fear porn
we're going to just tell you the truth
and it's not necessarily even exciting
actually what we teach people to do live
on less than you make live on a budget
these are not exciting things the
results however exciting you deserve to
make decisions based on facts and not
fear if you're wondering whether you
ought to buy or sell a house or the
housing market's going to crash what
makes it crash how this stuff works this
live stream is just for you we're going
to spend about an hour unpacking all of
that it's completely free
real estate reality check you need to
sign up for it in advance it will be
july the 14th just a few weeks away go
to
ramseysolutions.com
realitycheck
ramseysolutions.com
realitycheck our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings with free samples free
shipping and new promos they run all the
time you'll save even more use the promo
code ramsey to get the best possible
deal today's question comes from nathan
in indiana i'm 22 years old and
currently work 32 hours a week at 19 an
hour building crates for artwork it's a
far better job than i've had before my
employer is great but i'm concerned
because it offers little advancement i
can't decide whether i should continue
with
this current job or take a risk and get
a different job in a trade like
electronics or construction where i'm
guaranteed pay increases with each year
of experience trade jobs are high in
demand where i live so apprenticeships
are easy to get my goal is to be
financially independent as soon as
possible should i stay where i am or
pursue another career it's going to be
both and you're going to stay where you
are until you've figured out the trade
you want to be in if in fact that's
where you want to go and you lock in
that apprenticeship so what we really
want you to do is stay where you are
until you find a new ladder to climb
love that you want financial
independence i love that you've seen
that hey i'm limited here i have a lid
on where i am and that's okay don't
accept the lid but we don't just jump
there's nothing romantic or exciting
about that at all it can be financially
devastating so stay where you are until
you find that new opportunity to step
into and dave i'm very excited about
this question because you know america
our american economy really was built on
apprenticeships and this idea of the
paid apprenticeships in the trades
is certainly still very much alive it's
a great way to get paid
to learn and i love this option nathan
really good question yeah absolutely
so
i'm reading into your words
nathan as ken was into how you used your
words even the sentence structure and
the way you're asking the question
i'm a little bit afraid and i'm gonna
warn you against you take a 23 an hour
job and you leave a 19 an hour job
because it's in a trade and it
represents good advancement but it ends
up being something you hate
and you did it for four dollars an hour
and for advancement in something you
hate if you advance in something you
hate it means you hate it more
don't do that
okay so
ken is right slow down a little bit and
let's the trades are valid it's a great
place to make a lot of money there's a
lot of welders and diesel mechanics
making 100k
making a lot more than somebody who got
a degree in left-handed sociology
puppetry from
medieval art or whatever right i mean
you get these ridiculous degrees now and
you pay 200 000 for them and they're
useless makes you a barista
and so um
that's you you don't want to end up
there so i i applaud you on your
direction you're being willingness to do
hard work build crates
to do trades with your hands and uh now
but what you really have got to get into
is not
the near term
or even the next five years
but think out 40 years
okay are you do you still see yourself
as an electrician
when you're 53 or 63
and then if that's the case and you
think that's a great by the way being
electrician's a great trade
but if you don't see yourself doing that
if you're only doing it for four dollars
and because you can make more as an
apprentice and that feels better than
being in a quote dead end thing unquote
um that's the wrong move yeah and and
that's what i like about the
apprenticeship i'm getting paid to try
it but before we even get to the
apprenticeship how do you do this well
you've got to spend time with some guys
that have been doing it for 25 30 years
yeah and and they're going to tell you
the ends the outs the ups the downs do
you want to take that trade and then
eventually become an entrepreneur where
you start your own business in that
trade so it's absolutely the right
advice dave you got to look at the long
view
and it's got to be about heart it can't
just be about head what i mean by that
is it can't just be money related i've
got a really fine meaning in the work
and have an opportunity to make a lot of
money samantha's in houston hi samantha
ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so my husband and i have about 150 000
worth of debt
90 000 of which is car loans um
yes it's insane um
we
have talked about um selling our
vehicles i went to some places and got
an appraisal
um both of us are quite upside down on
the vehicles you must have rolled some
negative equity from the other deal into
it
yes well i guess so i mean when i traded
my car in i thought that i was right on
par but i was not and my husband knew he
was negative
um so we i went to my credit union i
asked them to vote negative into a
personal loan they denied me two
different times
um i am just at a loss what to do right
now our car notes are
extremely high
so tell me about car number one what is
it
okay so card number one my husband's
truck uh the loan on that is 53 000
and um it's a ford f-150 the car payment
is 1034 dollars good god sure all right
and um what the uh uh what did they tell
you that that was worth
um they're telling us that it's about
twenty thousand negative so thirty three
thousand is a value how many miles on it
oh this is truck yes uh the how many
miles i believe it's about 40 000 miles
how old is what year is the truck
2019.
uh go to kellybluebook.com yeah that's
garbage that's bullcrap that's a dealer
offer did you get more than one place to
look at this
uh yes i he went to um a ford dealership
and he's also talked to carmax
i talked to carmax today actually and
got an appraisal on mine that's probably
got to tell you about that next okay um
that sounds very low in
this market okay for sure used cars are
still selling very high i would check
kellybluebook.com and start looking at a
private sale i'm shocked to hear that a
2019 is 20 grand upside down now he
rolled some negative into it to start
with you said that but that's a lot okay
and then and your car then is what
it's a 2020 ford explorer um the
car that the loan that i that i owe is
thirty six thousand
uh payment is 573 a month
and uh today i got an appraised at
carmax for
27.5 okay well that means you can get uh
32 for it private sale probably so that
one's that one's within striking range
what's your um
meaning you could go get that other 4
000 out of your income in the next few
months uh what's your income
our income is 140 000. that's good news
okay all right yeah i'm sorry yours is
probably going first because it's easier
to get rid of
right
because it's closer i'm also going to
check the numbers because i want to make
sure he didn't just not want to sell his
truck
oh i i don't think that's what it is but
but yes please check
it's just it's like those numbers just
don't feel i mean i haven't pulled it up
and looked at it but that feels awfully
wrong but yeah you're right a thousand
dollar and a six hundred dollar car
payment those are two good things to get
rid of
and you get to get you a hoop a couple
of hoopties because y'all been doing
stupid car disease for a long time bless
your heart i'm sorry you are stuck in a
mess
you have identified the problem kiddo
and now the trick is to get out of it
you do any good over there yeah let me
tell you right now private market is
where they need to be looking they're
getting a dealer offer oh yeah it's
trade-in value but the truck did it did
you find anything on it yeah i found
some stuff you're looking at 45 to 55
000
for that i didn't think 33 was right
okay
this is the ramsey show
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build
wealth we've created more millionaires
by showing them how and causing them to
do it than most anybody else out there
we help people do work that they love
find place to make a lot more money and
doing something you actually love we
help people create and maintain actual
amazing relationships as opposed to
digital relationships did anybody ever
tell you those friends on facebook
aren't real friends
well maybe someone should tell you that
they're not your real friends dave they
really like my cat they won't they like
your cat laser pictures they won't show
up at two in the morning when your
tire's flat i'll just tell you that's
true open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money starting off this
hour's david in boise idaho hi david how
are you
hey fellas how you all doing better than
we deserve sir how can we help
um so my question comes i'm looking for
some advice i'm in this eight-year
beautiful relationship with
the woman of my dreams and
she's very much the free spirit and i'm
very much the nerd and i'm trying to
reel all of that in
i've got the bug for
getting debt free i think we accumulated
probably about 60 000 in debt we both
you know i think we're bringing about 10
000 a month
but
she's an in the moment person so and i'm
trying to
she wants me to do it first
and then she'll jump on board once she
sees
me start tackling it and then she said
she will join me but
i'm finding that very frustrating in a
sense that she'll blow through some
paychecks and then i'm dipping more into
my budget than
than i need to be doing so
i guess my question would be
how do i by the way i mean is that
possible because i find it it's just
frustrating and it's causing more fights
than anything
how old are you
uh we're both 38. okay
all right
well um let me first uh let's reset the
stage there's not a we you're not
married
right you're having an argument with
your roommate about how your roommate
handles money
and that's that's a that is a relational
problem but it's also a financial
problem because it's very very difficult
uh to
pretend like you're married financially
when you're not because the whole
dynamic has shifted
because there's all the legalities
involved
um you know there's no there's
no incentives involved you're still just
shacking up and you're 38 years old
and so you're gonna you're really gonna
struggle trying to pull this together
and act like it's marriage when it's not
i'll just tell you from 30 years of
coaching people that's the truth and i'm
not trying to pick on you or tell you
you're doing something wrong i'm just
telling you it's a very difficult
dynamic to pull off um
so what i would do is um
eight years is you know you're asking us
what we would do here's what we would do
here's what we tell you to do if you're
a son i've got a i've got a daughter
your age if you're my son i would say
here's the thing to do eight years long
enough time to paint or get off the
ladder
you know
you know you need to decide whether this
is real whether it's going to go forward
or not we're not just shacking up for
sex now this is a real thing
and so we got to make a call here uh
that's what i would tell my son if he
asked me and um and he was your age and
so
you're gonna struggle to prosper it
relationally until you make that call
and you're gonna struggle to prosper
financially and with the arithmetic
while you're trying to make that call
because she's legally got a set of
responsibilities you legally have a set
of responsibilities and they legally are
not combined the law all of the people
you do business with everyone recognizes
you only as two individuals instead of
one household unit and yet you use the
words we
like your income is somehow combined it
is not you have zero legal access to
each other's income at this stage of the
game
so that's what i would tell you to do
number one number two then is as a part
of that process
get some good pre-marriage counseling
and start to work on these differences
in your identities and in the way you're
approaching money there's nothing wrong
with one of you being a free spirit and
one of you being the nerd as a matter of
fact that's most couples
that have successful marriages they
learn to navigate all of that but when
we as a husband and wife have a vision
for the future and we are committing to
becoming and staying debt-free so that
we can
travel the world buy nice cars be
unbelievably generous and retire with
dignity change our family tree then we
need to stick to the plan that we both
agreed to but there's not a we right now
yeah and i'm gonna go back to something
you said david uh dave dave gave you the
fatherly advice i'm gonna be your big
brother for a moment uh
you said that her response to this was
well i want to see you do it see you
live out the baby steps
and then i'll get on board so my quick
question i got a couple things here are
you living it out are you attempting to
do it with your paycheck
yes and so she's seen me do it she's
seen you do it for how long
i've been going steady for about six
months okay so for six months
right so she's seen you do it for six
months and she's still on the sidelines
as your older brother for just this call
i have some real concerns here because
the woman of your dreams could be the
woman of your nightmares if she doesn't
get on board here and i appreciate what
dave is saying but i got to tell you
i would be having a serious conversation
uh before you decide to get married even
before you go into premarital counseling
and i think it comes down to this i
think you got to stop trying to convince
her
and i think you got to harness
her dreams in this conversation and cast
some vision
and it's a simple construct hey here's
the problem in the way that you're
living with your money this is what it's
going to lead to this is what it's
gotten you to here's the solution this
process i've learned over here and if we
do this
it's going to give us financial peace
and then our dreams can be bigger than
ever and we can do this dave i got to
tell you i want him i want to know if
she's going to catch this vision before
they even
get serious about marriage because that
really concerns me because of the the
rate of divorce you know if she can't
get on board with this yeah you got well
that's what i'm saying in pre-marriage
counseling yeah or some other way you've
got to get on the same page um or this
is going to end poorly because by the
way it's going to end poorly anyway
that's right if we don't fix this
it's just going to be an ugly breakup
that's correct you know and now we're
going to be fighting over who gets the
mustard
because we got confused about who had
the who what where the condiments in the
refrigerator came from you know i mean
mayonnaise is mine dead gummy and so you
know i mean that that's what you that's
how you fight with your roommate you
don't end up fighting with your spouse
that way that's right it's a different
fight with your spouse so yeah you you
you guys need to be going okay where do
we want to go
financially with our lives and what is
the best route to get there
not
i'm your daddy and you need to behave
yeah not you have to prove it to me
because i don't think you can do it and
i think this is unrealistic and i think
you're going to fall off the wagon and
then i'm going to have an excuse to not
follow through
instead look at it and go as a couple
where do we want to be in 40 years
and what are our steps to get there
i did pick 40 years not so randomly
yesterday was my 40th if you haven't
seen the picture go to dave's instagram
account it is
she's perfumingly beautiful she's
absolutely a beautiful woman now but i
mean and the amount of hair you had i
was the ass guy i was a pretty good
salesman i'm just saying that's all i'm
just saying and so yeah but i mean can
you imagine all the stuff we've been
through two hillbillies fighting for 40
years oh my god brutal
this is the ramsay shout
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today marks with us in st louis
hey mark welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking the call sure
what's up
i was wondering about donor advised
funds and trying to use that as a way to
be able to increase the amount of giving
we're doing as a family as well as
for the kind of one-time giving if
there's just something that
comes up having a good area where funds
are growing
to be able to give out of
uh one of my mentors had told me it was
a way that him and his wife had up to
their giving by about 50 when they
started doing it and hadn't heard it
mentioned it all on the show before okay
uh well they're excellent there are
several excellent ones uh out there that
do a good job uh the concept of donor
advised funds is obviously the
uh you are the donor you're placing
money into an account and you have to
advise
the fund where the money is to be given
to
um
and it has to be to a 501 c 3
in that case okay so otherwise if you
don't then it's not gonna there's no tax
advantage to it whatsoever uh you'll get
yourself in a pinch so you you know it's
all the 501c3 it does not increase
giving
unless you just increase your giving
it's just a vehicle through which you
pass money directly to the nonprofits
the only big difference is it encourages
you to keep it top of mind giving and it
helps you systematize your giving
somewhat which is all good and what to
your point earlier it allows you to hold
money past the calendar year
and so if you don't want to give if you
don't have a
a a ministry or a non-profit picked out
that you want to give it to and you want
to put 50 000 aside in december you can
do that and write that off
as a charitable gift and then decide
later who to give it to but it has to be
given
to a non-profit in that process that
makes sense
yeah absolutely absolutely
uh no that sounds
very similar to he's he was saying that
increase in giving was as much that once
you've put it into the fun
there's no longer that hesitation of
it's coming out of your checkbook so it
was more of an intentional
if i put this month this much in on a
monthly basis
you don't accidentally book that trip
with the money that you're planning on
giving good yeah okay i agree with that
but i mean once i set money aside for
giving in my mind it's gone i don't i no
longer emotionally struggle with that
but i'm so freaking compartmentalized
after all the years of doing it and so
we we moved in in the direction of a
personal foundation which is a the next
step up
uh much more expensive to operate much
more expensive to put in place donor
advised funds costs almost nothing to
run
and so
but we wanted to be able to do some
things with
some individuals like a single mom or
something like that buy somebody a car
that was uh struggling or something like
that without them having to be a 501c3
and all and so donor advised wouldn't
work for that plan
but it works perfectly for what you're
talking about and it is a really good
uh intermediate step
for your first level of
outrageous generosity it's much better
than just leaving the money sitting in a
checking account and accidentally buying
a couch with it yeah i agree with that
yeah yeah and then i think we're on the
side like if it's a
give somebody the car type option let's
just run those out of the checking
account do it as a gift donation right
off on those instead if we're not i mean
just my wife and i we're not anywhere
near the level of the foundation at this
point in time yeah yeah it's a good it's
a really good first step
and uh there's uh there's two or three
that have been around a long time uh
they've been very popular in the
evangelical christian community uh larry
burkett ron blue uh both uh
made them popular have served on some of
the boards they're both friends or were
friends larry's past ron is still
still a good friend
they both that's the first time i ever
heard about it and the generous giving
guys out of uh chattanooga tennessee do
a lot of work with outrageous generosity
as well
uh particularly in the faith spectrum
and uh they've been tied into some of
the donor advised funds it's a really
good way to look at it so it's a good
question thanks for calling us
can the giving part of what we teach is
essential to winning because it releases
you
if you can compartmentalize it like i'm
talking about or you move the money over
into that there's something that happens
once you decide the money's not yours
yeah
well and your behavior as you said we've
decided we're going to give this much
and so we live differently
we begin to see the return on investment
in a different category when we're
really given intentionally you begin to
go wow this is legacy stuff not just uh
401k mutual fund stuff not there's
anything wrong with that but it really
does change your entire perspective and
you know what's interesting is that i
think that
that you you in some way set yourself up
and i don't want this to be
misunderstood that if i i'm gonna make
more money i don't i don't believe that
uh as an action but i do believe that
your behavior changes and your
perspective changes so much that there's
a good chance you're going to end up
making more money because of that
change in perspective and belief well i
mean let's just face it we all can smell
a taker
versus a giver that's a good way of
saying that yeah and when you are a
giver physically logistically uh it
changes the way you smell it changes the
way you walk it changes the way you
smile you're the person that opens the
door for somebody that's got their arms
full of stuff you know the taker just
runs through and doesn't even notice
they're there uh and at different times
in my life i've been more than one than
the other sure you know so it's okay
wherever you start out but generosity is
not a a magical dna factor it's a
decision yes that's correct and it just
really puts into motion as you said it's
a likability factor you just have a
spirit about you and who tends to get
promoted people that are takers or
people that are givers givers i mean in
corporate america where there's politics
maybe the taker that's true maybe on an
hp maybe on hbo
for a season yeah the takers can get
ahead for a while but it comes back it
does it really does and the boomerang
effect is bloody it's bad but the the
giver is who you know if you're leading
two people and you have the perception
of wisdom and you actually believe as
their leader one of them's a giver one
of them's a taker you're going to
promote the giver every time
because you know they're going to
prosper the people under them that are
that they're leading the customers that
they're serving they're going to prosper
them they're all about generosity and
that generosity just the way they hold
their face is different yes it's
everything and it changes everything so
yeah it's an act you want to
intentionally plug into
and um the uh that's the process you
know and just it's it's fun and
important to point out too for those of
you that are right now baby step two
gazelle intense you can still give of
your time and you can give of your
talents in this season
mario is with us in new york city hey
mario what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call i
appreciate it sure how can we help um
yeah i'm 46 years old i'll be turning 47
in a couple of months uh and uh my
question is this apparently i had a
house where we live in right now
and uh i had a 30-year mortgage um i
ended up paying that off in about 12
years
and i paid off the uh the mortgage about
a year and a half ago good
so um i have about 1.3
sitting in the bank right now in cash
i have about 275 000 in the stock market
with the uh about 15 to 20 percent
correction that we already had
and uh
i'm in the market and i found this
property which is about a full family
home
will produce about seven thousand
dollars a month in rental
and it cost uh
a 1.2 million
and um
i was thinking to purchase it all cash
uh 1.2 cash and then that would leave me
with 90 000
in the savings account for emergency
fund
and it's kind of uh what's your
household income
uh 350 000 okay
i would want to build your retained
earnings up more quickly if you drain
yourself down this far on one property
because if you have a major event at
that property and loss of rent or a
repair
you could really get yourself in a pinch
there that's that's pretty tight but if
you're going to write a check and pay
cash for it
for god's sakes offer them a low ball
number
try to get a deal on it
um
you know i'm going to shoot anytime i
buy investment property i'm trying to
buy it a deal
i'm trying to write a check for cash i
can close it friday but it's going to
have to be a deal otherwise i don't do
it
and i just i made a lot of money doing
that with rental properties so
yeah that's where you want to start
i would buy it but i want you build that
return earnings back up as fast as
possible
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
healthcare coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage phil and mary are with
us hey guys how are you good good dave
great where do you guys live
rockford illinois cool welcome to
nashville and how much debt have you
paid off
paid off 45 thousand dollars in uh 17
months good for you and your range of
income during that time uh about 90 to
100. good for you guys cool what kind of
debt was the 45 000
uh we had two cars we had a little bit
of a student loan and we had some uh
house remodeling ah okay cool how long
y'all been married
12 years i'll let her answer that
[Laughter]
well played okay so after 12 years of
marriage 18 24 months ago you look up
and say something's got to change tell
me the story what happened uh kind of a
two-parter dave
it's
okay
big day uh
kind of a two-parter uh
initially we were doing davish we had
about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in debt
and uh our youngest was one and our
second was on his way
and uh i looked at the budget and i said
i don't know how we're gonna afford
daycare
but just miraculously uh my coach
football and one of the coaches just
happened to mention that uh him and his
wife were almost debt-free
and i started thinking about like wow
you can actually be debt-free you know
how does that work
and uh i also bartend and uh so one
night i got off a shift and i was
driving home and i flipped on the radio
and i just caught some guy's debt-free
scream very powerful
uh
started tearing up almost like i am
right now you know
and uh listened and listened and uh i
said i think we got to do this
and so eventually we signed up for the
course
and uh
you know it's just been pedaled down
since
we really committed uh 17 months ago so
that was dave ish and it was a pretty
hard davish
but 17 months ago we had a huge hail
storm
and uh
had some damage to our house
and so you know we only had 15 000 of
that initial debt left we had some
margin in our budget started to feel
comfortable and with the hail damage we
we took advantage we thought oh we can
put some money into the house now get a
new front door get some new siding
and the guy said yeah no problem we have
financing
and the real kick you know the punch to
the gut i got in the mail i got a credit
card
and i poof i just thought
i just thought we're not we're not doing
it
uh we're not doing it again it's over
so
17 months of a sprint you know i've
been trying to think of analogies uh
listen to the show a lot and listen and
heard a lot of people give some good
analogies about team work and and what
it takes and
i thought of it as a sack race where one
person couldn't just run
um we had to do it as a team
and uh so we did that and the last 17
months so we both just ran
as fast as
[Music]
just wide open
mary where's that emotion coming from
from him you've been in this journey
with him
he just worked really really hard and
sacrificed a lot for our family during
this time yeah so a lot a lot of time
away from you and the kids
uh it's worth it now yeah and that's the
emotion
yeah and that makes you never go back
never
ever never never never
yeah wow
very cool
so when somebody asks how you not pay
off 45 000 in 17 months what do you tell
them the secret is
well working together
i think you got to have the same goals
and you got to be um on pace with each
other we have to we had to coordinate um
a lot with work schedules and with the
kids and i don't think we could have
done that if we didn't have the same
goals yeah i think you got to be humble
and just tell friends i can't afford
that and
yes to work
he has to work yes to work he has to
work
i heard you say one time dave just draw
a line in the sand and if i never borrow
money again we'll get there and that was
back as a as a fail safe
and we just
worked from there just kept going from
there we're not brought money we're
going forward yeah what's up what's the
option what's the option what's the
option there's got to be another way
yeah got to be another two options stink
i'm gonna find a third option there you
go there you go keep keep looking to one
of them doesn't stink yep that's good
well done guys very very very well done
so if um
some guy's driving home from his extra
job and happens to turn on the podcast
later
it's got you on here talking about you
driving home from
the bartending job and kind of being
overwhelmed by that story
what do you tell them that the
what happens
inside of you when you really do reach
that point where you really are sick and
tired of being sick and tired because
dude i watched you physically change
right in front of me when you start
talking about that
i think uh for me i just felt suffocated
i just um i felt like i worked more
um you know having three different jobs
i worked with a lot of different people
and i worked a lot more hours than other
people
and uh didn't we didn't have anything to
show for and i didn't i didn't even
realize how much debt we had until
um
we did we looked at the budget and put
it down we had 15 different people that
we owed money to it was amazing i had no
idea that we had owed that much money to
that many different people
and that is overwhelming that's not a
place that i want to be or i want my
kids to ever be
amen well done who were your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
uh definitely our in-laws over here they
helped out a ton with with child care
and were very supportive of me going to
work quite a bit
and then a friend of mine corey corey
whitaker he's debt free as well
really helped support me
then i got a friend keegan hill who's a
who's kind of my accountability buddy
i'd tell him every time
we ended the debt and he was a good good
guy i love that so your football coach
yeah
when you were having those tough days
beyond just the
the vision for the future for you and
your family how did that coaching come
into play when you just didn't think you
had any more to give
um
boy that's that's hard to see i think i
was
really focused with
with football there were definitely
things
that i would say the younger coaches can
tend to
um but with the kids
and my kids i you know i always trust
we're going to take care of what we can
take care of we're going to be the
toughest guys on the field and that's
the way we're going to handle ourselves
i love that
well done good stuff guys way to go i'm
proud of you thank you how does it feel
to be free
great it's awesome
yeah good
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away and the financial
peace university membership for a year
and uh you can give that away to
somebody or you can go through it it's
all the 20 it's all the brand new videos
that we just launched the other day all
right you brought the kiddos let's bring
them up what are their names and ages we
have bria who's 7 and nolan who's 5. all
right if they've been practicing their
debt-free scream yeah all right good
stuff i love it well done you guys all
right it's bria nolan mary and phil from
rockford illinois 45 000 paid off in 17
months making 90 to 100 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three
two one
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i love it
that is absolutely wonderful
man what a what an incredible story very
well done yeah you know it's it's really
awesome dave to look over there and
see a man's man a football coach just
totally brought to his knees in
gratitude those those two those were
tears of gratitude and appreciation uh
to make it through this journey and be
on the other side of that and just
that's pretty cool that's about as
that's about as manly of a man you'll
ever meet right there and and we need
more of that you know that's that's
incredible stuff stuff it takes to serve
as family and yeah you know make sure
stuff gets done yeah very very well done
good stuff guys very very well done
you only change your life when you
finally say i've had it
i'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired
there's no amount of intellectual
gymnastics are gonna make you get out of
debt you gotta get pissed off
i'm done
i'm not living like this
that's when you change
not until
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author well inflation is
affecting all of you right now from the
gas pump to the grocery store and while
you can't control what happens with the
economy you can control what happens
with your money the only way to control
your money in uncertain times is to get
on a budget and the best way to budget
is with every dollar you'll plan out
your monthly budget you track all your
expenses throughout the month and every
dollar mobile app lets you check in and
check your budget from anywhere so you
can always make the right money
decisions when you get on a budget you
will be in total control of your money
and really not until
start budgeting for free by going to
ramseysolutions.com
every dollar
this is the ramsey show we're glad
you're with us america patty is with us
in boise idaho hi patty welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up um
i have a dear friend who is recently
divorced and i'm trying to help her go
through your baby steps i've walked her
through them
i've
tried to explain everything to her but
i'm really stumped on advising her in
one area and i was hoping you could help
me advise her correctly
um
she because of the divorce she has to
refinance her house she has to
put it in her name
and she has a car that she's upside down
on and by your plan it tells me sell the
car right
but she's
five thousand dollars
on the car
even if she does private sell
and
she doesn't have any money at all to buy
a car so she would have to borrow even a
couple thousand
to buy another car
so i don't know if i should have her
roll this into her baby step like just
put it on the list of her that she has 8
000 of additional debt besides this car
and her house
or if
i should have her roll it into her house
which you know you always say don't do
so i feel really uncomfortable telling
her that but i'm just not sure how to
advise her the best way to go about this
i'm glad she's got you in her corner
obviously it's all right
she got little kids
she does she has an 11 year old and a 13
year old and her house is worth 390 000
but to refinance it she has to
refinance for 165 000.
the requirement was she had to get her
ex-husband's name off the loan
what does she make
so
working two jobs with child support and
renting a room on her house she's
bringing in 43 000 a year
she's stretched really thin time wide
like she's just really
she was really taken
by surprise and had no idea about
finances she's not going to
like my answer
but it is the right answer for her
okay
she cannot afford this house
well so i thought about that and like
the problem i have with that is i didn't
ask about your problem i said she can't
afford the house no i know the the
market though in for her to even rent
like her house came in
she makes 45 000 a year and the only way
it works is if the roommate pays their
rent
and her ex who surprised her before pays
child support there's a lot of variables
here that are going to cause her to get
in trouble
so do i advise her to
sell the house hail the debt off pay all
the debt off buy a car for cash and go
rent the cheapest thing possible and
heal
from this process
rebuild build a career where she makes
more money obviously she's going to do
that long term um but this house here's
what happens and i've seen this for 30
years and it just breaks my heart
but
and let me tell you what's going through
her mind maybe even yours
is
these poor children have been through so
much already
and they're hurting and in order to
protect them from even more up evil and
more change dad's no longer there
there's all this weirdness in their
lives for god's sakes we don't want to
change school districts and we don't
want to make you move out of your
bedroom
and in the name of that she's trying to
hang on to the last vestige of normalcy
that she can
in a way that is completely unrealistic
were she not in this house and was
sitting with this pile of money from the
equity in the house in the middle of a
kitchen table there's no she would no
more go buy this house than fly to the
moon
this is trying to maintain
the story that was and the story that's
gone
okay and it's up i appreciate her mama
bear instincts to do that for her baby
but it's a
it's a short-term fix because what what
she's trading for is tremendous
financial stress in these kids lives in
the coming five years
and everything's in order for it to be
normal she's going to be so spun up
trying to keep everything you're trying
to run around keeping different fingers
stuck in the dike as the dam continues
to leak
and it's just gonna get worse and worse
and worse and i'm sorry i've just seen
it hundreds and hundreds of times
and um it took me a little while to
realize why people were doing this
illogical act but it was in the name of
protecting some stream of continuity
in the middle of a a
a complete up evil where their their
their story that was going to be their
life is completely changed and it's been
a nightmare for her and for the kids
and the last thing i want to do is make
a move i'm sorry i i wouldn't do that
does she then take some of that equity
and get herself some sort of
like i had her do uh ken coleman's
yes yes
yes okay there's listen a house is not a
home a home is where you make it
right and when home is full of financial
stress following a divorce
it is very difficult to stay on an even
keel
and even be somewhat classy about the x
because you every time you're in a pinch
you're just pissed again
it's just very hard to go through the
healing process when you pile financial
stress on top of
the mess that's right you're surviving
instead of healing yeah you have one
track mind survive survive survive it's
all adrenaline you can't heal you know
and i don't know if i've talked you into
it or her into it because she's gonna go
look out there and go what about this
what about that i think you rent the
cheapest thing possible buy you a cash
car spend some money on some
certifications on a career track and
five years from today you're going to be
in a much better place than you are
trying to hang on by your last
fingernail on this one old house and
it's just a stupid house
it was the home
but now it represents the dream that was
the broken heart yeah patty hang on the
line we're going to give you a copy of
my best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose she's not ready to read this now
uh but when she gets everything settled
financially and they get out of there
give her this book it's kind of the
companion to the get clear assessment
it'll help her
begin to take steps forward to a much
better financial life because of her
income and independence so hang on the
line we'll give that to you as well take
one more step at stab at the persuasion
patty because here's what's running
through my mind
she's got seven years with this
eleven-year-old
where are they going to be in seven
years if they do what i'm talking about
and what does the next seven years feel
like inside the home is it peaceful
joyful
hope-filled for the future
or is it stressed and freaked out and
barely making it all in the name of
trying to hold something together that
was the past
and
i think that 11 year old is going to
have a much better teenage set of
teenage years with a mom who's peaceful
stable
building her whole new life building a
whole new dream
getting her certifications
moving towards home ownership again in
the future doesn't have a debt in the
world and is dealing from strength and
courage rather than a mom that's hanging
on by a thread
barely making it
hoping the child support comes in and
hoping the room may pays
man that just doesn't sound like fun to
me
and uh that's that that's this 11 year
old's next seven years where does he
need to live what's best for him
and what's best for the other one the
next
eight years nine years whatever
ten years from today this lady is going
to be in a great
life
but she's either going to have walk
through more hell to get there or she's
going to have started from taking a two
or three steps back to solid ground to
start fresh again and that's what my
hope for her is and i'm sorry she's
going through this it's just it's just
not it's
it's not good
divorce just it's bad it just messes up
everything man it's horrible
so sorry so sorry
hey thanks for the call that puts us out
of the ramsey show in the books austin
shelby ben hill zack hendren andrew
holmes james and kelly in the booth i am
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and build and create actual
real amazing relationships
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five renee starts off this
hour from harrisburg pennsylvania hi
renee how are you
i'm good dave it's nice to talk to you
and ken you too what's
up well i'm calling because we're baby
steppers and uh so
my husband and i are on baby step seven
um and we were
we were planning to uh get land from my
relative he was going to gift us a piece
of land next to our current property
and
he since changed his mind he's not
not going to
gift us the land any longer he wants to
charge us 60 000 for the lot
now our only problem is is he's only
told us that in 30 30 days ago and
we are now we are not prepared for that
we don't have the money we don't have
the cash and so we're looking because
it's family land that's been in the
family since the 60s
and it's currently next to our current
property um
and we're concerned that we don't like
we would like to build maybe next to us
at some point or we're not at least not
keep a home from another home from being
built and so we wanted to know like
should we take out a loan and if so like
i don't really want to take out a loan
but
i don't want to also lose this this
family land um and it's now or never
he's listing it tomorrow and so we're
looking at taking out a heloc on our
current home and we we do own our
current home
you don't have any money
no savings we just completed your plan
here in january oh so you just paid off
the house in january
yes and you don't have any money in
retirement investing at all
we do we have we have we
are doing our 15
and it's more because um we
obviously reached baby step seven so
we're doing i
how much is in your emergency thirty
percent
um twelve thousand okay what's your
household income
about 70 000.
[Music]
okay
um
wow
well that's inconsiderate on his part
you are kidding
must be your husband's side of the
family
unfortunately it's mine
[Laughter]
have you tried knocking a noggin on him
not going to nod on his noggin we've
tried
we're offering better deals we've tried
offering 50 instead of 60 we've tried
everything we could think of would you
make us let us know in the world
from giving it to you to selling it out
from under you
cancer so he's had cancer for at least
the last 10 years
he has lung and leukemia and
um he's trying to get it cleaned up for
his because the medical
the medical bills are expensive always
trying to pay medical bills
yes and his financial advisor has
advised him not to pull from his
investments obviously because the
market's down
to pay those medical bills
and he's well off
because my my
own father
passed and so he received the rest of
the inheritance from my grandparents
oh then your dad's portion didn't pass
through to you
no
that's weird okay
huh
well i've asked every question i can
think of i don't borrow money
and i don't like being
jerked
around into deals that are
aren't on my timing so i have a tendency
to walk away from this kind of thing
but mainly because i'm just so
rebellious and sometimes i do it to my
own detriment
i have regretted it before
and um
so i'm trying to be a little bit even
keel because i'm pretty ticked at your
little uncle right now um he's got the
money to pay his medical he does not
need money to pay his medical bills
okay he's got the money to pay his
medical bills and his medical bills
aren't that much he's got insurance
it's not even 60 000 right and he's got
plenty of money and if he pulled 10 000
out of his stupid investments it
wouldn't kill him
in spite of the fact the market's down i
wouldn't pull it out because the
market's down but i would pull it out
before i
broke my word to my niece
so well the other the other benefit for
him is that there's another lot next to
it and he's going to be selling it
so it will go on the market tomorrow and
he will be able to sell that
and he can get whatever you know
whatever
from the from the realest
uh it's about three quarters of an acre
so it's not huge but there's sewer
connection available so let's let's talk
about it from two different perspectives
then all right number one dave and
sharon ramsey don't borrow money
and so we would have to just pass hard
pass
the money all right a place to get the
money without borrowing it we'd have to
hard pass because i just don't borrow
money and once i've gotten my home paid
off and i'm baby step seven the chances
of me going back in debt i just that
would be like throwing up a little bit
in my mouth i couldn't do it but that's
how we feel no it's so i would just say
uh you should have kept your word to me
and and i'm sorry you've got cancer but
i'm also sorry you don't have integrity
and i'll be checking checking that box
and moving on uh now having said that if
you go get a home equity loan for sixty
thousand dollars and you pay it off over
the next two years and you're 100 debt
free and you've got this lot and you've
got a buffer the story still ends
excellently
um and uh
you know you're gonna be just fine
you're not gonna keep that debt forever
you're not it's not gonna break you you
could pay it off and what you could pay
it off in two years really couldn't you
well we when we did the math we were it
was more like four
yeah that's not good enough you need to
do it in three
minutes yeah maximum of three i'd rather
i'd rather you i'd rather you do it in
two
um because this is almost like you know
i don't like home equity loans i don't
like any of this
but it is a singular piece of property
it's not a nice lot that you found
across town it's a singular piece of
property that's family dirt it's next
door to you it gives you buffer
and so on um but even the other side of
that you're still going to have a house
right
yeah so you're not you know i got 120
000 right
no
we tried we tried offering uh less but
he would not take that either we tried
to buy both lots
i'm just getting redneck right now i'm
going to try to stuff them both but you
do whatever you want to do
if you do the home equity loan and take
them and um
pay it off real fast it's not the end of
the world financially it's just i
there's
when deals like this come at me i
sometimes do the wrong thing out of
abstinence
um admittedly and so
um
i i couldn't do it for multiple reasons
just because i don't like being lied to
and i don't like being jerked around and
i really don't like it when it's
freaking relatives
so yeah
that'd be the end of that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today is there an area of your
life that feels off balance and you're
wondering what the right next step
should be
maybe you have uncertainty about your
money or a starting pr or just want to
start prioritizing your mental health
maybe you want to find purpose in your
career or improve the health of your
marriage whatever you're facing it's
important to do it with a community of
people by your side encouraging you
along the way and what better way to
grow than with a few folks you love
doing life with you can level up
and experience all of this at smart
conference with your friends
saturday october 22nd in dallas
smart conference is a one day event
designed for you
you'll hear from world-class speakers
all day long your favorite ramsay
personalities will be there plus our
good friends craig and amy grochelle
from life church are coming and the best
life changes happen when you have
support accountability and you're around
a bunch of people excited about being
smart check it out
start today you can get a four pack of
event passes for only 120 dollars that's
30 a person for a whole day
of all of some all of america's best
speakers i mean teachers this is an
incredible incredible event
thanks for joining us victoria is with
us in pennsylvania hi victoria welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thank you dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
well you see so we just uh discovered
you me and my boyfriend probably this
week and we're looking to make my
emergencies fund and i have a trust fund
that probably has i'm gonna say probably
about thirty thousand dollars in it
uh but the only issue is my mom is the
i'm gonna stay like the holder of the
account right now
she's not really giving me access to it
since i became over the age of 21 now
i'm 22.
she's making it pretty difficult to
access that money so we were looking
just to get it out so we can start the
emergency fund what are the terms what
are the terms of the trust
so it was originally made for schooling
but i've already had my degree and they
made me
she actually had me pay out of pocket
for that whole degree because she didn't
want to touch the money so i was
probably about five thousand dollars
that i spent on schooling
um
but she won't let me touch any of that
you have a copy of the trust
um i have the information i've actually
been in contact with the trust and they
were just like hey she just has to sign
this paper and then it goes into your
name
and she will not do it because she
thinks i'm going to be a
quote-unquote stupid kid and blow all
the money
okay the but the terms of the trust say
that it's to revert to you controls to
revert to you at 21.
uh yeah but because i was underage when
it was made she just won't find it over
no no no stop you're not underage now
right the terms of the trust say that
the money is to be turned over to you
after age 21. correct yep and she just
has to she doesn't have to sign anything
she doesn't have to sign anything
okay get back in touch with the trust
company and tell them you're going to
contact a lawyer and sue their butts if
they don't turn your money over to you
okay
she's no longer a trustee of a trust
that is now defunct because you turned
21.
okay
i'm not a lawyer but that's if you if
you have a lawyer look at this situation
that's what they're going to tell you
yeah that's going to be the next step we
were just trying to figure out if that
was the right step or just trying to get
her to sign it over would be the best
step well i mean for best step would be
that she doesn't need to sign it
because of the terms of the trust and if
you've actually reviewed them uh i would
get in touch with the trust company and
go uh the terms of the trust are that
it's 21 is turned over to me there's no
signature required on her part if you
don't turn it over to me i'm contacting
legal counsel so you need to do this
right now
yeah just try them and just have them
send you the money and that solves the
whole thing you call your mom up and
tell her what you did
yeah she's trying to exercise control
over something she no longer has control
over what i'm saying
yep especially since i moved out she
does not have nothing to do with moving
out of me has nothing to do with moving
out the terms of trust don't state you
have to live with her they don't state
you whether you live they don't state
where you live they state where you're
that you're 21 period
yeah
okay
if you go to do something stupid with
this money you ought to have your butt
kicked
yeah i do
okay
if you go screw this up if you go screw
this up you ought to have your butt
kicked but that doesn't change the fact
that legally you have right to this
money
yeah based on what you are telling me if
you have correct information
yeah i
should probably just uh
go over the trust and specifically what
it says and if
it just says 21 then they should either
write me a check or
or
we're going to have an attorney contact
them and tell them to do that yeah
yeah
and then you can call mom and say mom
i've retained legal counsel because
you're illegally holding this
you need to sign the paper and turn it
over to me now
well there you go that's an easier
answer said than done
well it is and
thus is the problem but yeah
that's the deal hey thanks for the call
i hope that's all that information is
right because i don't know your
situation but it does sound like you
need to you need legal advice
once you've gone through the details of
the trust if you can't get mom to
release it to you and you think the
trust says it's to be released to you
and based on what you're telling me
that's my advice to you so
good question thanks for the call
okay so here's the rule ken um
nothing wrong with doing a trust
and it's not unusual to do a trust for a
minor
until they turn 21
and at 21 is turned over to them and
sometimes it's later it's turned over to
them
the mistake that was made in this
situation was
they appointed someone to be the trustee
who did not have the
the intellectual power to do it
because mom is trying to function like
mother and not trustee and it's going to
get mom sued yeah yeah
uh so you can't you you can be a mother
and you can have motherly opinions and i
might even agree with her mother maybe
victoria doesn't need this money maybe
she's acting out maybe she's immature
maybe she's gonna blow it i already told
her not to blow it right just like her
mom would have told her right but uh but
those instincts are different than the
actual legality of a trust a trustee
is only allowed
to do what the trust states
correct they're not allowed to insert
their own opinion
or advice into the situation unless the
trust states that yeah
in which case you have really opened up
a pandora's box of a mess i was curious
what you thought about what we heard
here now i think it's fair that victoria
i don't know that she's read the fine
print i don't think she's going to which
is great but
does it strike you as odd that the trust
would say to her well we need a
signature from mom you would think or is
this a bad assumption on my part that
they know what it actually says and they
were in fact telling her what isn't what
is in fact true
i truly have no idea why a trust company
would be unless they're just out of an
abundance of caution trying to keep mama
happy right they don't want mama coming
back after him too right she's going to
be pissed when this goes down yeah so
that's my guess is they're just trying
to play politics here rather than
legalities which they're going to get
their
tail on a crack too yeah that's going to
be a problem so the problem is when you
assign a trustee
then the trustee
uh you know what there's no trust there
is no trust company she's the trustee
yeah so something she's she she must
have gone to a bank account and a banker
told her that that's what i'm wondering
like because that struck me as odd yeah
what you have to do then victoria is
take a copy of the trust into the bank
right and show the branch manager look
this is what it says and the every
minute that you hold this past this
you're going to be liable
yeah and just that's what i was
wondering because the trust is just the
document that says here's the deal that
manages
sometimes there's a trust company but
the trust company i mean a trust
department a bank can act as a trustee
exactly but the mama's the trustee on
this no question and she's mad that
victoria left the house yeah according
to victoria so didn't like the boy
yeah
but and all of that may be accurate
doesn't matter though in this case well
it matters is so point being that the
takeaway for all of you in america is if
you're going to form a trust be careful
who you appoint as the trustee it is a
tremendous responsibility
and they can get themselves into a
problem if they start inserting their
own
opinions
into the application of the legality of
the trust
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage jake and kelsey
are with us hey guys how are you doing
well doing well good to have you guys
where do you live
irvine california all the way to
nashville all the way across the whole
stinking united states way to go guys
come in thank you for coming and how
much debt did you pay off
we paid off 456
000 in six years
300 000 of that was in the last three
years
wow
good for you and your range of income
during that six years we started at 175
000 and we ended at 285 000. cool what
do y'all do for a living i'm a teacher
and he's a physical therapist
okay and so wow great incomes
so uh
what what in the world what kind of debt
was this
student loans yeah primarily student
loans we had one car built in there but
it was all pretty much made up of
student loans 456
in student loan debt for a teacher and a
pt
oh it was foolish in the beginning but
when we were signing up for things it
was just it'll be our problem in the
future we'll worry about it later
and then
obviously it became our problem yeah how
long you guys been married 12 years we
actually had our anniversary on um
saturday oh happy anniversary very good
okay so uh halfway through your marriage
six years ago
that student loan's just still sitting
there almost a half a million dollars
staring at you
and you you wake up in the middle of not
in a cold sweat i mean what happened
what in the world what changed what
changed the direction on this so we grew
up in minnesota and then we moved to
california for jake's physical therapy
school
and when he was in school we knew that
we wanted to get rid of the debt somehow
we just didn't know what the plan was
and so while he was in school we were
living on the teacher's salary and i had
a long commute and i listened to the
dave ramsey's show on my commute and so
i asked jake if he was interested in
trying the program and basically the
minute he got out of school we started
running and
i would say at the beginning we were a
little bit dave-ish and then that's when
the last three years you saw how we
picked up and really worked to pay it
off yeah 100 grand a year for three
years
you were after it i mean you're on beans
and rice absolutely jake at one time was
working for jobs
so he's an inpatient physical therapist
so he was working at four different
hospitals
that became a little too much so he
scaled it back but
we sacrificed a lot of time i didn't see
him a lot
i did summer school
he worked really hard you know 10 hour
days every weekend i would tell people
jake works every day and i think they
heard jake works a lot it was jake works
every day
all day yes a lot of days yeah for a lot
of days in a row for three years there
amazing wow
powerful
uh guys there's so many times
that i have sat with people or talked to
people here on the air either one
and they have a mountain of student loan
debt like this and you guys are
incredible
uh because that was uh a wee bit
daunting
to look up and go i got 450 000 on a
teacher and a pt's income
because neither one of these are six
figure incomes usually uh but the way
you worked them you turned them into
that
oh my gosh amazing
yeah i gotta ask because just the strain
on your relationship just not seeing
each other then you're exhausted you're
working uh every day as your wife said
what kept you going in some of those
dark days
it was um
definitely knowing what the future held
and kind of as the one question we
figured you'd maybe ask about
is
one of the keys is sacrifice and um
we definitely made the most out of our
time
um on the weekends a lot of times when
i'd come home
we knew we knew we'd maybe go to church
we'd prepare a meal we'd eat we'd visit
with friends for a tiny bit and we'd
have maybe one to two hours together so
we really learned to cherish those one
to two hours
and we knew that once we got over with
this
life was going to be so much better on
the other side and a few months out it
certainly is yeah have you had a moment
to kind of emotionally and financially
and relationally exhale a little bit a
little bit
um has it hit you you know what in a
sense it hasn't because i'm still
working some um working our way through
the steps and i actually jokingly have
told kels a couple of times when i go to
work on the weekends it almost feels
natural like when i'm going to work
extra jobs and extra shifts
when i stay home it actually it actually
feels more abnormal kind of like what
are you doing here on the weekend
um but it's it's starting to sink in
it's starting to feel real that um all
the hard work that we did for these
years is paying off did you have a sense
of release when it was gone
definitely we knew the day that it was
going to be gone and we had the loan
company that we were going to call and
do it and we had cookies made
with uh with uh getting out of debt and
stuff and um
and
so once we made that call and once it
was processed
we definitely felt the relief
yeah wow okay i'm going to go back to
what i said a minute ago the the
450 almost 500 000 is daunting
because most a lot of people give up
right there
it's too overwhelming i can't get there
it's hard to it's hard for people to
internalize the belief the hope that
they can ever get there and you guys did
it in six years most of it in three
years
what do you tell that person who says ah
man there's just no way i can't i can't
i i kind of see how you guys did it but
i can't believe it for myself you know
what i'm saying all right
they need to definitely believe in
themselves and then like we're living
walking examples a teacher and a
physical therapist and we made it work
as we said it talked it really comes
down to dedication
and hard work and
definitely sacrificing and planning
yourself i think that you have to have a
goal i don't think there was a day
that we didn't talk about the debt every
single day we talked about it and i
think that's sort of been the release
now too is you don't have to talk about
that but you have to have that goal that
you have to find something else to talk
about
what are you doing home and what am i
supposed to say to you
exactly but um i think that people just
have to figure out you know what you can
do that you can work those extra jobs
that you can be willing to sacrifice um
ours was a longer journey and i think a
lot of people sometimes
are shorter and so it's just what are
you willing to give up you know i mean
we drive a 1998 camry so i mean there's
things sometimes you have to give up to
get to the goal that you want at the end
well it's time for you to buy a car now
i mean you really do need to get a
better car that one sucks oh my gosh it
still works yeah i know but yeah you got
you got to break loose man you got to be
done i don't want you go crazy here but
go pay cash for it for sure but oh my
gosh i mean you have worked so so hard
i'm so proud of y'all y'all are an
amazing couple
and and uh you kind of look like you got
a little ptsd a little bit like you're
still trying to little shell shock still
from
you gutted it out so dramatically i mean
there was so many years of saying no and
we can't do this we can't do that um now
like we you said the release is yeah
coming taking a trip to nashville uh
going to visit family doing things like
that that we said no to a lot over the
last several years so um now we get to
enjoy these things on a much grander
scale do you feel um
when you do want to take on something
this size do you feel accomplished
quite yeah um if we did this we could do
anything exactly yeah exactly all along
the way um kelsey and i always tell
people that once we even got towards the
end we could already feel the freedom
you talk about the peace and it's
indescribable even when we knew we
weren't fully done we still felt as you
mentioned the release already
you've mentioned before it always feels
like you're giving yourself raises all
along the way and
we for the longest time never even had
to think much about money because we
knew where it was always going to be
going
and now we just kind of transition that
into
better ways to
save and invest i think we felt the
peace along the way
too it was um at first it was so
daunting to put all those student loans
and see them but once they started going
like we felt like we had more money even
though
every month our money went out the door
but you just felt that you had that um i
think because you're giving every dollar
a name and knowing where it's going
that's good they had you you felt a
sense of control before you were even
debt free because you actually were in
control good for you yeah hey we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that's going to be a cakewalk
i hope so yeah really and uh we got a
copy of the
total money makeover book and a
financial peace membership as well you
guys are incredible you're heroes i'm so
proud of you thank you so much jake and
kelsey irvine california 456 000 paid
off in six years 300 in the last three
years making 175 to 285 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
wow
that's pretty fun boys and girls
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day colossians 4 2
devote yourselves to prayer being
watchful and thankful
president john f kennedy said as we
express our gratitude we must never
forget that the highest appreciation is
not to utter words
but to live by them
amen well done good stuff
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
marsha's with us in evansville indiana
hi marcia welcome to the ramsay show
hello thank you for taking my call i
have been listening to you since april
5th of 1995
and i finally got a question i just need
your opinion on
okay uh should i buy a piece of farm
equipment so i can section 179 expenses
for next april's income tax
no
now let's talk about why uh the way you
stated all of that the only reason
you're doing this is for income tax
yes okay no
and uh 179 it means you just get the
only thing about 179 is you get to write
the whole thing off in one year you
don't have to put it on a depreciation
schedule
correct okay so how expensive a piece of
farm equipment
between 80 and 120 okay let's call it
100 for round numbers okay yes sir are
you in a what a 30
tax bracket 35 tax record
no no actually i'm in the 21
next year uh it'd be a 25 but this year
it's a 21. okay so you're gonna write a
check for a hundred thousand dollars for
a piece of equipment you don't
need and the actual the actual
mathematical benefit needed i'm sorry
i wouldn't say i didn't need it yeah i
could do without it but i would use it
yeah well i'm sure i mean if you bought
a new airplane you'd use that too but um
but that's not the point
the um
so that you can you can 179 that as well
if you're using it for business but the
um
uh the point being this okay the hundred
thousand dollars leaves your checking
account and then you take a 100 000 tax
deduction is your income in a in excess
of 100 000 a year
uh 98 is what i expect for this year
depending on the grain market okay
so you would pay zero taxes
on the 98 000 and it would have been
around 20
actually around 15 probably because it's
a graduated tax income tax it's not all
the final bracket but so let's say your
tax bill on the 98 000 would be 15 000
yes i yes exactly and then if you didn't
pay
if you didn't have this write-off you
pay 15 dollars
so you're trading one hundred thousand
for fifteen
can i ask you one other thing then did
it make sense to you
yeah absolutely uh we did not
take any crop last year
until january of this year so i already
i already know from my tax lady i will
be spending fifteen thousand dollars in
taxes
for the 2021
crop okay and so if i were to buy this
piece of equipment
and 179
i'd save 30 000
okay but you're spending 100 to save 30.
true
yes
i agree
i mean if you want trade dollars for
quarters i got a deal for you
well it's like what else do i do with
the money my stock i'll do that deal
with you how much do you want to do i'll
do 500 000 with you if you want to do
dollars for quarters
walk away slowly marcia
[Laughter]
so here's the thing what's the piece of
equipment
uh it would be a used backhoe or a dirt
mover okay
all right so here's the only reason you
buy equipment in business
the only reason
it makes you
more than it costs you
yes i agree when i buy computers for
this place i can 179 them
when i buy cameras for this place i can
179 them
and i spend a lot of money on that kind
of thing every year around here
so i when i furnish offices i can 179 up
to a certain limit okay but i don't buy
any of those things for the 179 tax
write-off benefit i take the 179 tax
write-off but i only buy them if i can
make more money because of them than
they cost
and you're not going to increase the
quality or the your income on this farm
by as much as this equipment costs
i agree so you're not roi and you're not
getting a return on investment on the
equipment and you're only buying this
for a tax write-off which is trading
dollars for quarters
and you don't do that and i question
whether you ever take a piece of
financial advice from your idiot tax
person again
this is horrible advice
well it was my idea and they they agreed
with me okay well
uh then i i won't be quite so harsh
since i have you on the phone but oh my
goodness oh my goodness darling no we
don't want trade dollars for quarters
people do this all the time in business
and call it smart and it's it's because
they're usually because their tax
accountant is only looking at the tax
benefit of it not at the actual economic
transit transaction and the economic
transaction is you're handing somebody a
hundred thousand bucks and all you're
getting for it is 30.
that's not a good
trade it's not a good trade i hate taxes
more than you do but i ain't trading the
dollar for a quarter just for that now
i'm gonna take the 179 write-off every
single time on items i purchased because
they were going to make me more than
they cost me anyway that's correct and
that and i believe me i max my 179 out
every year and trump's tax law really
helped those of us in small businesses
one of the few things that small
business come along a long time that 179
being maxed out like like entire floors
of stuff we could write off around here
instead of writing it off over three
years or five years we wrote it all off
in one year
so the small business person is the fear
is the answer to that fear oh i'm going
to get a tax bill is it retained
earnings just juice that a little bit
yeah you got to set your money aside for
taxes right so then you don't need to be
so worried about it yeah so it doesn't
bite you but you just you just get sick
of giving the government money because
they're stupid trust me i don't like
giving stupid people money i get that
and i'm looking to see the size of the
money they take from me
so that i am a law abiding citizen yeah
and uh otherwise i'm not a law abiding
citizen oh my gosh you know and but it's
just thievery in the name of government
yeah and so i don't i don't disagree
with her in that sense i god man it
pisses me i don't want to do it it just
makes me i stay mad around tax time but
i'm also not going to trade dollars for
quarters in the name of keeping money
out of their hand that that's just
cutting off your nose despite your face
kathy's with us in canada hi kathy how
are you
hi gentlemen thanks for talking to me
today sure right quick before we run out
of time what's your question yes um okay
i'll make a quick i'm newly single i
have three children 43 years old
starting from scratch i'm getting 150
000 settlement from my ex
any day and i'm wondering
just pay off debt and and
start from scratch or
or invest it and try and build it i'm
just scared i'm starting over how much
time over again
i have a 28 000 car and 40 000 line of
credit plus my house
68 plus your house what do you owe on
the house yes i owe 180 it's worth 240.
what are you going to be doing for a
living
i'm a correctional officer for the
federal government up here pay your
bills on that
oh yes okay i grow some about 1 30 and i
met about 80. so
i'm okay i just
wanted child support as well or just
this one cash in your no no
yeah we're 50 50. so none of that i'm
really nervous i'm sorry okay you're
fine you're doing good and you're
helping me you're helping me meet the
clock for a run out of time here so here
we go there we go
i would pay off the debts and start
fresh and make sure you're living on a
tight budget so you don't get yourself
uh messed up on your new income being
less than it was when it was combined
okay okay be very careful to live on the
130.
yeah i've been binging your books i've
been i've been
budgeting like crazy so i feel like i
just want to start this off on a fresh
foot and not make big mistakes so
whatever i might have one of the things
i did when i started fresh after going
broke in my case in your case it's a
it's a divorce
but the um one of the things i did is i
went back to the old debts and i said
okay what was going on inside of my
heart that allowed me to do that i want
to make sure that's healed
so how did those debt where do those
debts come from
and make sure that part's healed so they
never grow back
after you get rid of them that's a good
thing to look into and go well it was
all him he was stupid okay then that's
fine
we got rid of him so we're okay
it's one way of healing from it
ken good show today thank you sir austin
ben zach andrew james and kelly in the
booth i am dave ramsey your host will be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you